what's going on guys this is Rob and I'm
actually really excited to bring you
guys something I'm excited to bring you
guys Marvel's own crate in fact it's
it's it's basically there's really no
need for loot crate I think at this
point you know what while having their
own crate initially I wanted to do loot
crate but I think loot crate kind of
sucks now because I think loot crate was
initially really popular but it got to a
place where people were basically saying
like hey we'll pay you money if you put
our content in your crate and the result
was that we ended up getting saddled
with crates like orphan black number one
which was an absolutely stupid crate but
nonetheless you know with with this is
basically like a direct from the
manufacturer so to speak kind of crate
in the sense that this is called the
marble collector cord and this is
Marvel's very own crate you can actually
get it directly from Marvel I was
looking for an alternative a loot crate
you know after after the the covert
crate whatever was that loot crate
offered in March now it was like okay
this this is garbage like this company
probably gonna fail pretty soon so I was
like I wonder if there's an alternative
and I was poking around online and there
were like all these other alternatives
whatever and then Marvel was like we're
announcing our own crate and so April's
crate is the very first crate so I'm
pretty psyched I'm really really
interested to see what they have to give
us so with that being said let's let's
crack this open let's cut this thing
open if I can do it okay so let us open
this up I'm pretty excited Wow
holy cow okay well this is amazing all
right so look at this this is one of the
first things we get is this massive
thing on top this it's this an age of
Ultron themed crate so this is a Marvel
collector Corps collector core exclusive
I'm wondering how many of these actually
gonna give us like how many exclusives
we're gonna have or this is really just
like a first first issue or first Marvel
core or mobile collector or you know
exclusive thing but this is the
some bobblehead it says it's a hole
Buster armor vinyl bobble head so let's
let's open this up let's seal them here
nice and tight I'll get one one okay
let's put that there and we'll put that
right over there too okay well this is
cool here's what here's what it is this
is actually pretty interesting I like
this like it's it bubbles bobblehead
this is cool this is a fun little action
figure to just kind of sit around um you
can't really do anything with it I mean
it doesn't look like you can move okay
yeah you can't so I wouldn't play with
them I wouldn't give him to like a three
or four year old kid you know this is
more for just you know having having
sitting stationary you know but it's
it's cool like I like that you know
that's pretty interesting
okay the next thing is this right here
which is cool this is like a collector
Corps collector Corps badge of some kind
which is pretty interesting I like this
I mean it's this cool I guess you could
you know attach it to something or just
kind of fill it in somewhere or
something like that I mean it's it's
interesting okay the next thing is this
oh so vinyl figure is what it says this
is so let's open this up looks like it's
an age of Ultron figure okay
well that's cool like it's this little
thing right here I mean that's
interesting I mean again there's another
little figurine for you to kind of sit
around and and just sit on a desk or
something like that I mean that looks
kind of cool you know not too bad
and then there's okay cool here's a
lapel pin it's what this looks like
something you just like physically
attached you know I wanna do a shirt or
something like that and of course you
got the button so you would just take it
apart and then you would you know attach
from the back and that's that's cool let
me I like that you know cute little
button alright next is a t-shirt and
what does this t-shirt say I don't want
to knock my thing off the table this
t-shirt says hold it up so you guys can
see it alive at the infinite avengers
mansion watch the heroic high-flying
avengers no home TV presented by marvel
no-strings match Hulk vs Ultron that's
cool I mean it's it has I like that I
like the you know watch the heroic
high-flying
Avengers tag like I like that it has a
very like early Silver Age 1960s Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby feel to it like I
like that you know that's that's that's
a pretty cool thing I think okay and the
final thing is I would expect it to be
it is a comic book I was expected to be
a comic I don't know why Marvel wouldn't
include a comic with their own unboxing
or their own crate but this is guardians
team up Avengers number one so Avengers
I guess the New Avengers and guardians
of the galaxy team-up so that's that's
cool this is what the cover looks like I
wonder if this is like a standalone or
if it's written by Brian Michael Bendis
okay so it is the entire galaxy is a
mess warring empires in cosmic terrors
plague every corner someone has to rise
above it all and fight those who have no
one to fight for them guardians of the
galaxy are Peter quill star-lord
Gamora the most dangerous woman in the
universe Jack's a destroyer the
mysterious warrior Angela venom Captain
Marvel Rocket Raccoon and Groot wow that
is an all-star team oh that's actually
pretty cool so it's written by bindas so
this looks like it's in continuity um
this is actually pretty cool I like this
but it's the guardians and Avengers
team-up number one so I'm interested to
see what comes of that but that's that's
pretty interesting huh pretty psyched
but yeah so so not a bad crate um not
bad at all you know for a beam
first crate I'm sure and and I actually
kind of what I expected here was that it
might might contain you know an early
version of Secret Wars number one which
is supposed to be coming out for free on
May 2nd so I thought I might include
that but I'm not disappointed not by any
stretch of the imagination I'll have to
do is just go to my comic book store on
May 2nd and get it for free so but um
yeah that's cool I like that I mean
that's that's a that's that's it's a
good crate it's a good starting crate um
I'm curious to see where they go from
here I'm sure they're measuring the the
popularity of this to decide what
happens next but uh but yeah so I'll
have a link down to the description that
you're welcome to check out you can go
ahead and look at the Marvel collector
Corps if you want to it's a crate that
actually comes out every two months I
think I don't think it comes out every
month so it's it's a really good thing
you know to to enjoy I think so I'm
terrible at closing videos out but um
yeah so I'll catch you guys later peace